SEAN HANNITY IS NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT.
WE HAVE ALL THE ANGLES AND NEW
INFORMATION COVERED TONIGHT.
FIRST WE HAVE LONG REPORTED ON
THIS PROGRAM, GOING BACK THROUGH
2007.
YES, JOURNALISM IS DEAD.
AND ALSO THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
MOB IS NOTHING MORE THAN AN ARM
OF THE EXTREME RADICAL
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
AND BASICALLY THEY ARE LIKE ONE
AND THE SAME.
REMEMBER, MANUFACTURED CRISIS,
THEY USE THE SAME WORDS.
TONIGHT WE HAVE MORE PROOF.
TONIGHT A JOURNALIST WHO WRITES
FOR "THE HUFFINGTON POST" ."
HE TOOK TO TWITTER TO EXPRESS
HIS OUTRAGE.
ACCORDING TO ALI, SHE TRIED TO
INTIMIDATE HIM.
NOT ON BEHALF OF NBC NEWS, BUT
ON BEHALF OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
NOW, OLLIE WROTE THAT THE
MISCONDUCT WAS HIGHLY
INAPPROPRIATE AND UNETHICAL.
SHE WANTED THE REPORTER TO HOLD
OFF ON PUBLISHING THE DATES OF
AN UPCOMING PRIMARY, NOT TO HELP
NBC, NOT SO HER NETWORK COULD DO
IT FOR A SPOT SO THAT THE DNC
COULD INFORM STATE PARTY
LEADERS.
WHY IS SHE ADVOCATING FOR THEM?
HE SAID SHE WAS CALLING TO BULLY
ME INTO A PUBLICATION ON AN
INNOCUOUS GROUP.
IT WAS ONLY ABOUT THE DNC.
SHE REMINDED ALI THAT SHE WAS A
NATIONAL SECURITY REPORTER AT
"THE WASHINGTON POST" FOR TEN
YEARS, AND THEY WOULD HOLD
THINGS ALL THE TIME.
SO HOW CAN COMCAST, THEY ARE THE
POWERFUL PARENT COMPANY OF
NBC NEWS, ALLOW THIS KIND OF
CORRUPTION IN ITS RANKS?
JUST LIKE A WHOLE NEWS CHANNEL
FULL OF TIN FOIL HOT CONSPIRACY
THEORIES?
I HAVE A VERY IMPORTANT QUESTION
FOR EVERYBODY WATCHING AT HOME.
ARE YOU AT ALL SHOCKED THAT
NBC NEWS IS WORKING ON BEHALF OF
THE DNC?
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE I SAID SINCE
OH SEVEN, JOURNALISM IS DEAD AND
BURIED?
RIGHT NOW THEIR CREDIBILITY
FRANKLY COULD NOT GET ANY WORSE.
AFTER ALL, THE TWO PLUS YEARS,
AND THEY LITERALLY NOW HAVE BEEN
SHOWN TO BE LIARS.
THAT'S EVERY WEEK, MONTH AND
YEAR.
AND NOW THEIR AUDIENCE, THEY ARE
LEAVING IN DROVES.
LOOK AT THIS.
>> Sean: >> President Tru
>> Sean: >> President Trp
>> Sean: >> President Tr:
>> Sean: >> President TrT
>> Sean: >> President TrE
>> Sean: >> President TrM
>> Sean: >> President TrD
>> Sean: >> President TrA
BOSSES, BAD PEOPLE.
THE CROOKED JOURNALIST, THE
TOTALLY DISHONEST TV PUNDITS.
AND BY THE WAY, THEY KNOW IT'S
NOT TRUE.
THEY JUST GOT GREAT RATINGS.
BY THE WAY, THE RATINGS DROPPED
THROUGH THE FLOOR LAST NIGHT.
>> Sean: IF THEY HAD THEIR
AUDIENCES EVERY SINGLE DAY AND A
NIGHT ON THE EDGE OF THEIR
SEATS, COMING, COMING SOON.
IT'S DEFINITELY HAPPENING.
AND, THE MUELLER REPORT ENDED
ALL OF THAT.
WHAT YOU SAW IS THE MOST
DRAMATIC PRECIPITOUS DROP IN
AUDIENCE WITH TIN FOIL HOT
CONSPIRACY TV MSNBC, FAKE NEWS
CNN, AND HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF VIEWERS.
THE MEDIA OF COURSE WANTED THIS
PRESIDENT TO BE GUILTY OF
TREASON.
THEY WANTED HIM TO FAIL
SPECTACULARLY.
THEY STILL DO.
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE STILL
REMANDING THAT THE MUELLER
REPORT BE RELEASED IN FULL.
>> WHY WOULD HE LIE WHEN HE
KNOWS HE IS RELEASING IT AND NO
ONE WILL SEE IT?
PRETTY BIZARRE.
>> WE DON'T HAVE THEM MUELLER
REPORT, THEY ARE COVERING UP AT
THIS POINT.
THIS GUY IS NOT RECUSED AND IT
FEELS LIKE A COVER-UP.
YOU ARE HIDING BEHIND
DONALD TRUMP'S OWN ROY COHN WHO
SQUEEZES TOGETHER A COUPLE OF
SENTENCE FRAGMENTS AND PUTS IT
IN A LETTER, WHILE TRYING TO
KEEP FROM THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
THE MUELLER REPORT.
>> THEY COMPLETELY SAID NO
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION, JUST LIKE
THE FBI SAID AND THE HOUSE UNTIL
SAID, JUST LIKE THE BIPARTISAN
SENATE COMMITTEE SAID.
FOR THE FOURTH TIME, NO EVIDENCE
OF COLLUSION.
BUT THE MEDIA THAT HATES TRUMP
WITH RAGE, THE MOB, THEY
DESPERATELY WANT THE FULL
MUELLER REPORT RELEASE.
BUT THEY NEVER ASKED THAT THE
PHIS APPLICATIONS INTO CARTER
PAGE RELEASED.
THEY NEVER TALK ABOUT THAT
EITHER.
REAL RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE IN AN
ELECTION, AFTER THEY RIGGED AN
INVESTIGATION INTO THEIR
FAVORITE CANDIDATE, AND THEY
THOUGHT SHE SHOULD WIN
100 MILLION TO ZERO AND THAT WE
SMELL WALMART VOTERS THAT ARE
AIR POURABLE
DEPLORABLE.
THE CLOSED-DOOR TESTIMONY,
THAT'S ALL GOING TO BE COMING
OUT.
THE TRANSCRIPTS WE GOT FROM
PAIGE AND PETER STRZOK AND
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
THEY DON'T WANT A FULL AND FAIR
CLINTON EMAIL INVESTIGATION.
THEY DON'T CARE IF THERE IS A
DUAL SYSTEM OF JUSTICE, NO EQUAL
JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW.
NO EQUAL APPLICATION UNDER THE
LAWS.
WE DON'T CARE IF THEY FOLLOW THE
CONSTITUTION, THEY DON'T WANT AN
INVESTIGATION INTO THIS RAMPANT
ABUSE OF POWER.
WHEN NONE THE MEDIA, THEY FIND A
LINE AND CLING TO THAT.
LIKE IT'S A MATTER FROM HEAVEN.
AND, NO EVIDENCE OF ANY INSTANT
OBSTRUCTION FOR A CRIME THAT WAS
NEVER COMMITTED ANY WAY.
I SPOILER ALERT, NEW NARRATIVE,
IS A LIE.
AS POINTED OUT LAST NIGHT ON
THIS PROGRAM BY RUSH LIMBAUGH.
>> WE ARE BEING LED TO BELIEVE
THAT THIS REPORT DOES CONTAIN
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
BARR IS LYING ABOUT IT.
IF IT CONTAINS EVIDENCE AND
COLLUSION, THEN WHERE IS MUELLER
ON TELEVISION ALL NIGHT?
SAYING, WAIT A MINUTE.
MY REPORT HAS PLENTY OF EVIDENCE
OF COLLUSION BUT I HAD ALL THESE
ANTI-HILLARY PEOPLE ON MY STAFF.
WHY ISN'T MUELLER DOING THAT IF
BARR IS LYING ABOUT THE REPORT?
>> BREAKING TONIGHT, LIKE HE
SAID IN HIS FOUR-PAGE LETTER
LAST WEEK, HE IS GOING TO
RELEASE THE MUELLER REPORT
MID-APRIL, IF NOT SOONER.
AND THERE ARE NO PLANS TO
RELEASE THE REPORT TO THE
WHITE HOUSE FOR PRIVILEGE REVIEW
WHICH BY THE WAY I THINK IS A
MISTAKE.
THAT'S APPARENTLY BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THERE IS NOTHING TO HIDE
AND ALL THE MEDIA LYING AND ALL
THE SPECULATION, YOU KNOW WHAT?
IT IS DEAD WRONG.
AND BARR SAID HE PLANNED TO
RELEASE IT.
SO WHY WOULD HE SEND OUT WORDS
THAT WOULD BE CONTRADICTED TO
WHEN HE RELEASED IT.
THEY WOULD DEMAND HE WAS FIRED.
BAD NEWS FOR THE MEDIA AND GREAT
NEWS FOR THE COUNTRY.
THEY NEVER REPORT ABOUT THE
SUCCESS OF THE PRESIDENT AND THE
RECORDS THAT HE BROKE.
SO WITHOUT A DOUBT, A MOMENTOUS
WEEK, NOT ONLY FOR THE PRESIDENT
BUT ALSO FOR THIS COUNTRY
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE CAME DANGEROUSLY CLOSE AND
ARE